agua y más agua escenarios como este han
marcado los últimos días de muchos
peruanos el ciclón yaku se saldó con
inundaciones acompañadas de fuertes
vientos a su paso que solo en la región
de Lima ya han dejado a más de tres mil
personas sin casa se votó mi casa
o sea me dejó sin nada solamente
nada más y sigo también igual mi nietos
igual y como usted ve Ahora a poder
levantarme de nuevo pase de trabajo pero
con cubos algunos intentan despejar las
inundaciones para salvar sus viviendas y
pertenencias Y es que la temporada de
lluvias que comenzó en septiembre ha
causado muchos estragos en el país
sudamericano con decenas de muertos y al
menos 12.000 damnificados han dicho
defensa civil que tenemos que subir por
lo que vivimos todos al contorno del río
para prevención porque para que no nos
pase ya nada los equipos de rescate se
han tenido que desplegar en las zonas
más afectadas y escenas como esta
se han vuelto cada vez a más comunes
para intentar garantizar la seguridad de
la gente de la zona no tenemos nada como
perdimos todo absolutamente todo el
ciclón denominado como no organizado y
estrechamente relacionado con el
fenómeno de la niña ha pillado las
autoridades a peruanas por sorpresa y ha
obligado al gobierno de Dina boluarte a
declarar estado de emergencia en 400
distritos del país